uh speaking of which is another tangent
I want to go on uh the most I the most
iconic scenes involving bathrooms and
toilets in movies and TV shows
what the the the most iconic scene
involving bathrooms and toilets in
movies and TV shows the only one I can
think of is uh in [__] Trainspotting
when he dives into the toilet to get the
drugs oh yeah other than that they're an
iconic scene oh and uh something about
Mary no I don't think I've seen that
movie have you not seen that movie with
a come yes he like Jack explained he
jacks off into the mirror before the
date right I was jacking off before
there's something about Mario is that
something else something about Mary I'm
pretty sure right because it's still all
right yeah it is
um it's got uh Cameron Diaz yeah yeah
that's something about Mary right is it
can you can you Google this make sure
um okay so so there's two there's two
yeah yeah so there's that and then
there's the scene which I think like
explain the first scene all I hear so I
think yeah he's having a date and he
wants to you know because he might be
getting sorry he wants to jack off
before he goes out so you know maybe
that's a lot yeah yeah and he comes and
he doesn't know where the come went
yeah and then it turns out it was on it
was behind his ear yeah
Cameron Diaz at the door and she's like
oh you have some gel I'll take that and
she takes it for some reason and puts it
and puts in her hair yeah and um yeah
yeah
is it actually possible to be good hair
gel breaking it down but no no the scene
I was thinking of I don't know if this
is still there's something about marry
them it might be something else but uh
it's the zipper scene
where I can't remember this one I think
I think it is Ben Stiller he's a
he's uh pissing in the toilet yeah and
he just kind of like he's just staring
out the window right and he's just kind
of like like having like a thousand
yards there or whatever and then he
realizes he's staring at the window of a
girl getting changed or something like
that right and so he starts to panic and
then he zips up
[Music]
you've seen this scene to me and I feel
like it's Steve Carell in my mind I
don't know why like why am I picturing
40 year old maybe this is Steve curl
scene as well maybe there's a Steve
Carell scene but he's remade it yeah
yeah but it's hanging homage yeah but
it's iconic because even just describing
that every every man in the world
basically you hear him zip up every man
in the world winces he zips up and he
screams and then and then there's this
oh God it's a [__] iconic scene
there's a scene where he uh he asks for
help and basically every guy who's just
like okay let me let me help you they
they look at what they look at what has
like what he's what he's got himself
into yeah and they're just like yo what
the [__] man what the [__] and the most
[__] up thing is there's a shot while
they actually show what has happened oh
there's a shot where the zipper is
entangled with the skin and it's just
like for a second how do you just are
you that is that is now like become a
core memory that has become a core
memory in my mind oh my boss and
everyone and everyone who's watched that
film oh I'm gonna google iconic bathroom
scenes because now I'm the only one the
only other one I can think of is uh I
forgot which Austin Powers film it is oh
no uh but there's that scene where he's
inside the the lair of uh doctor evil
yeah and he like runs into the bathroom
and uh and and as he's taking this like
extremely long piss the two two henchmen
are talking like some like secret you
know talks or whatever but he can't hear
him because the piss is so loud so he
stops to listen and the henchmen just
like
we'll get him really suddenly and he
just starts pissing he's like and he
just does that on and off for like five
minutes that's the only other one I can
think of Home Alone one where he's
getting changed and then he slaps his
face and goes ah with the Aftershock was
that woman what was that in Home Alone
when he he's you know getting ready and
then he applies the aftershave to his
like bare skin yeah and he screams
because obviously it burns yeah he's not
a man yet I had my my leg up and all the
blood's rushing back to my leg
I did find the scene you're talking
about uh it's from uh Along Came Polly
right oh yeah I'm getting those two
mixed up and still in Jennifer Aniston
okay okay yeah okay Ben Stiller an
iconic bathroom scenes man what can you
say so there's The Shining technically
in the bathroom oh yeah it is Johnny
[Applause]
I actually heard a really fun uh well
like I guess little factoid about that
is that like the actress uh I forgot her
name but you know how she's like [__]
terrified and screaming yeah that was
apparently a genuine reaction because
she didn't know that they were actually
gonna get a real ax and actually go
through the door so she's actually
freaking out well Kubrick was a [__]
madman yeah okay [__] yeah okay he
wasn't as he made amazing [__] movies
but hearing some of hearing about some
of the uh hearing about some of the
stories that happened on set on in
everyone in his films he is I would hate
to work there was also there was also
that scene in The Shining that I think
apparently took 127 takes yeah he's
crazy yeah and they made them redo it
just so they can get mentally fatigued
and actually [__] just crazy yeah
because of how many times he asked them
to redo the take what an [__] and uh
in the Clockwork Orange where they had
the scene where they uh propped up the
yard oh yeah they actually scratched his
corner or something like yeah and so
when he's screaming stop stop he was
actually screaming because yeah like it
was legit scratches cornea and he was
like screaming in pain and Kubrick's
like keep rolling keep rolling this is
great this is a good take this good film
this is I mean back back way back when
movies just were starting and becoming a
big thing and a lot of money was being
put put into like a lot of people just
died during filming stuff yeah Big
scenes like Coliseum scenes or yeah
there's a Noah's Ark
film which a bunch of people died well
there's a famous one of like uh you know
the never-ending story uh no uh it's
like this fantasy film The Neverending
Story like really famous in the US but
uh there's this scene where like the the
kid is like pulling a horse through a
swamp yeah and the horse like slowly
starts to like sink apparently that
horse actually died way back in animals
and movies they did not give up at all
straight up died in that scene and they
cut it right before the horse actually
like drowned and died and I'm just like
what the [__] that is depressing yeah
it's super depressing yeah the only
other thing I can think of is
um that's it there was a Texas Chainsaw
Massacre where there's a scene where the
first one I think it's the first one
there's a scene where because the
because it was so hot where they were
filming and uh the main murderer had to
wear like the mask during filming and it
was [__] he was getting like heat
stroke and he accidentally like there
was a scene where he cuts like one of
the uh one of the girl's finger yeah and
he actually cut the finger and she was
screaming in real pain
was so delirious that he like didn't
know that he was actually cutting like a
real finger
just like the [__] you can get away with
like back then God someone someone's
getting a lawsuit nowadays
I'm looking at more iconic bathrooms
yeah what's the more iconic bathroom
scenes but put iconic [__] scenes
[Music]
I mean there's the I mean again going
back to Austin Powers with the Fat
Bastard you know like sitting on the
toilet he's like but I didn't have any
calls there are so many iconic bathroom
scenes and lots of powers thinking about
like that first scene when he wakes up
and he's like dethawed and he spends
like ages on the urinal and he's just
like that's because Austin Powers is
like the epitome of like pee pee poo poo
yes in film it's like it's that's why we
love it
um I'm actually going to check gbt like
10 iconic grouping scenes yeah well
there's a woman Dumb and Dumber where
they have the laxatives he drinks
laxative he started [__] oh there's
also that scene in White Chicks as well
where he has the cheese accidentally
yeah
I love that scene
um God White Chicks is a film that would
not fly today no I'm just thinking about
it that would be a film that would be
canceled so fast this big Tropic Thunder
could be made nowadays no no American
Pie there's like so many there's one
where he's like shaving his pubes and he
for some reason throws the pubes out the
window and they they get blown into like
uh and a one of the wedding venues oh my
God every other scene in American Pie is
like half what happened to toilet humor
I remember when every other like comedy
film had toilet humor in it and and now
we're just like oh we're better than
that
I don't think we are because I still
love that line in uh in American Pie
where it's like I went to band camp and
I played a trumpet with my [__] like
it's it's the dumbest line but it's
stuck with me for all these years oh
yeah any nuts and sunscreen yeah that's
gross I love those movies